Y a pas de saison pour que vive la musique
Au fond, pas de saison pour que vive le son
En marchant tu donnes une cadence à tes pas
Tu sens la musique au bout de tes doigts
Tu dis que la vie qu'on t'a donnée est faite pour ça
Tant de choses, grâce au son, tu connaitras
Ton coeur est un saphir de pick up
On a trouvé des décibels dans ton check up
Et tu chantes, chantes, chantes ce refrain qui te plait
Et tu tapes, tapes, tapes, c'est ta façon d'aimer
Ce rythme qui t'entraîne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
Réveille en toi le tourbillon d'un vent de folie
Tu danses le monde, musique américaine
La cadence du funk, au plus haut t'emmène
Le tempo en délire, si ce soir il fait chaud
C'est qu'on monte nos mains vers le point le plus haut
Et tu chantes, chantes, chantes ce refrain qui te plait
Et tu tapes, tapes, tapes, c'est ta façon d'aimer
Ce rythme qui t'entraîne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
Réveille en toi le tourbillon d'un vent de folie
Et tu tapes, tapes, tapes, c'est ta façon d'aimer
Ce rythme qui t'entraîne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
Réveille en toi le tourbillon d'un vent de folie
Toi qui dessines au fond de ton ennui les notes d'une
mélodie.
Une musique sans accord majeur c'est une piste sans danseur
Mais si tu ranges, dans ces moments là,  dans un placard tes idées noires
Les notes pourront se danser et nous reviendrons les chanter
Quand le sucre est tombé choqué le café renversé
Je sentais bien que la journée etait mal commencée
Plus tard la caisse était cassée avant que craquent les
chromes
Mettant la gomme j'avais detalé
La musique était mon sourire les vieux succès mes
souvenirs
On sent tous son dernier soupir lorsqu'on va mourir
Mais un souffle j'avais gardé car on ne peut pas trépasser
Chacun le sait sans voir un disque jockey
Et tu chantes danses jusqu'au bout de la nuit
Tes flashes en musique funky
Y a la basse qui frappe et la guitare qui choque
Et y a le batteur qui s'éclate et toi qui tiens le choc
Et tu chantes, chantes, chantes, ce refrain qui te plait
Et tu tapes, tapes, tapes, c'est ta façon d'aimer
Ce rythme qui t'entraîne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
Réveille en toi le tourbillon d'un vent de folie